el flagelo del hobbit 19 en
latinoamérica está poniendo a varios
países contra las cuerdas en ecuador' en
la víspera de las elecciones
presidenciales la ocupación de un
hospital en quito la capital supera el
130 por ciento algo que refleja la
situación del país y ha obligado a
montar carpas para que el creciente
número de pacientes no quede desatendido
algunos de ellos han inspirado por más
de dos días para ser atendidos que
incluso teníamos pacientes en el piso
espera esperando una asignación de una
cama los cuales tenían que esperar de 48
a 72 horas sin embargo como hospital por
garantizar una atención digna una de las
carpas habilitamos como hospitalización
esto es lo que el hospital puede crecer
técnicamente es su máxima ampliación más
de eso no sería técnico y el crecimiento
mientras en chile la situación no es
mejor en el último día el país volvió a
superar los 8 mil contagios con una
segunda ola del virus que ha hecho que
la tasa de ocupación de las ucis
super el 95 en colombia el gobierno
impuso cuarentena durante este fin de
semana en grandes ciudades del país con
mucha ocupación en las unidades de
cuidado intensivo tras el rebrote
ocasionado por las vacaciones de semana
santa una situación similar a la de
argentina donde hoy entran en vigor
nuevas restricciones eso que debería de
ser un poquito con el tema de reuniones
más
menos flexible porque en realidad creo
que un problema de sociedad que las
personas no son un tanto consciente de
lo que está pasando y se quejan de las
retenciones que bueno respecto aquí pero
hay muchas personas que se aglomeran
todo el tiempo y eso genera muchos más
índices de contagio incluso países como
uruguay líder en vacunación con más de
un millón de personas inoculadas la
pandemia está causando estragos por lo
que la presidencia ha decidido alargar
las restricciones durante todo el mes de
abril